[Musique]
je suis
mais
la plus belle tenue
[Musique]
belle
ma tenue de liberté
j'ai eu une enfance difficile
j'ai perdu mes parents très tôt
et je me suis retrouvé chez ma grande
mère
à Daloa
jeunesse j'ai eu un fils
je ne voulais pas que cet enfant vive la
même situation que moi
alors j'ai décidé de me prendre en main
je confirme mon enfant à mon frère aîné
je suis allé chez ma cousine à San Pedro
quand elle m'a demandé les nouvelles je
lui ai dit je vais travailler
elle dit quoi je veux travailler
et elle a fait appel à sa camarade qui a
un match
j'ai commencé à travailler là-bas en
tant que service
j'ai vu que l'argent que je gagnais
là-bas
ne pouvons le prendre en charge
mon fils non plus
étant dans le maquis je fais la
rencontre d'une d'un groupe des
responsables
et je me suis confiée à la dame qui
était parmi le groupe là
et là
le lendemain quand ils sont revenus pour
manger dans le Vaki là où j'ai travaillé
la dame m'a donné leur adresse
et je me suis rendu là-bas à ma pause
le monsieur que j'ai trouvé m'a dit mais
ça c'est un travail d'homme est-ce que
tu vas pouvoir le faire
je dis je vais pouvoir le faire
il m'a dit tu viens tel jour on va te
poster
[Musique]
et je suis allé remercier
du maquillage
le lendemain je viens on envoie sur un
site étant sur le site je travaille avec
un jeune
son téléphone et je vois une image des
femmes européennes au volant des gros
camions
quand j'ai regardé
ça m'a fait un goût dans le cœur je dis
ça je vais être comme je vais comme ces
femmes là
il me dit comme ça d'un coup de magique
t'as pas le permis je fais comme les
femmes là je le regardais je dis ça
passe ou ça passe
j'ai commencé à économiser
un jour j'ai vu un poteau électrique
où on parlait de permis toute catégorie
promotion
je me suis renseigné et je suis allé
là-bas
la dame qui m'a reçu tout ce qu'elle m'a
demandé j'ai donné
elle dit je peux commencer quand tu veux
aujourd'hui tu peux commencer
le lendemain j'ai commencé
quand j'ai eu mon permis là c'était en
je suis revenu
le gros camion
voilà l'occasion que j'attendais
et le chauffeur du parti
je vais voir le patron
à la formation des chauffeurs il m'a
regardé comme ça il dit où est-ce que tu
as travaillé
avec la question quand je l'ai écouté il
a fini je lui ai dit que j'ai jamais
travaillé dans une société
mais j'ai versé de l'argent à une
auto-école qui me fait la main il dit va
voir le responsable des chauffeurs
dis-lui que je vais l'appeler
et je me rends chez eux
je dis je viens vous voir de la part du
patron et puis de me mettre sur la liste
il était dans son fauteuil il a tourné
son fauteuil une fois deux fois trois
fois il s'est calé puis je suis arrêté
tellement j'étais contente le même jour
j'ai déposé la lettre
et la formation la semaine qui a suivi
la formation a commencé moi je n'avais
pas l'info que la formation a commencé
c'est mon mari qui est venu qui m'a dit
mais la formation a commencé et puis toi
tu es là et tu dis quoi
on commence quand il dit demain
jour je suis parti on a fait la
formation il dit il faut que tu fasses
les choses pour le chef hein
donc je me levais à 4h du matin je
préparais du riz et je venais donner au
chef
quand on va en formation parce que nous
ne faisait pas il ne le faisait pas au
garçon c'est à moi quand on va en
formation à 16h avec le camion
sans goûter c'est moi qui paye moi je
n'avais rien le peu que monsieur me
donne sur moi c'est ça je prends pour le
nourri comme mon enfant
je paye ses petits crédits de 500 qu'il
avait envie de vivre qu'il avait en
ville mais moi tout ça ça me disait rien
parce que il y a un but que je vais
attendre
il y a un but que je vais atteindre
à la fin de la formation il y a eu des
moments où
on dit d'apprendre à faire la marche
arrière pour les garçons 5 ou 5 pour moi
la femme 4
donc les garçons et il a aussi exigé que
je sois la dernière
donc les garçons qui faisaient des
fautes et puis il est brundai j'ai
essayé d'enregistrer pour faire moins de
photos et c'est ce que j'ai fait
ce qui avait 5 tours
je me suis débrouillé
pour avoir mes quatre coins je me suis
retrouvé en tête de tous ces hommes
[Applaudissements]
à la fin de la formation
ou tout le monde me disait félicitations
pour toi tu as tué pour toi c'est clair
sur la liste
à la fin
je n'ai pas retenu
et là
j'ai pleuré parce que tout les larmes de
mon corps
un jour pendant que j'étais triste
quelque part là-bas monsieur vient de me
dire
c'est pas la fin du monde avec un ton
c'est pas la fin du monde il y aura
d'autres occasions
et c'est là que j'ai arrêté de pleurer
et puis j'ai repris mon travail de
gardiennage
de
2003 que j'ai eu mon permis le permis à
3 volets de 2003 jusqu'en 2013
peut-être 10 ans d'attente
je ne suis pas découragé
parce que je voulais forcément ça
et je suis resté là
trois ans après on dit une société qui
veut dire aussi les chauffeurs
donc je vais poser ma candidature
en fait pour la première fois c'est pas
parce que je n'ai pas le savoir parce
que j'ai mal fait on ne veut pas tout
simplement de femme là-bas
cette corporation là on ne veut pas de
femme là-bas c'est tout
et la seconde société
même pour me prendre ils ont dû
consulter mon mari secrètement
est-ce que tu es au courant il dit oui
je suis au courant et elle a mon soutien
[Applaudissements]
et c'est là
que j'ai été réputée
à la fin de la formation le grand patron
a demandé pour se faire la main pour
commencer aller chez le client
il faut qu'on soit formé
individuellement
trois mois pour chacun
sur les trois mois moi j'ai fait trois
semaines et puis on m'a donné mon camion
[Applaudissements]
j'ai commencé à aller chez les clients
un jour j'arrive à la gare la jeune
jambes le chemin
il y a quelqu'un ici il dit qu'il n'a
jamais entendu que une femme qui roule
il n'a jamais vu mais si c'est avéré va
se suicider ce jour-là donc ils ont
bloqué le chemin
pour d'autres c'est une pente logo
camion il voit un gros camion avec avec
un conteneur donc c'est une femme de
deviner que ce qu'on appelle je vois une
équipe une petite histoire je vois une
équipe qui vient avec un monsieur un
monsieur costaud ce qui marche comme ça
qu'on appelle dans nos
Ivoiriens
et il a donné de l'argent
il faut le faire alors il est parti et
ils ont livré le chemin je suis parti je
vous assure je me suis sanctifié et ça
m'a donné plus de courage
et ça m'a donné plus de courage
une fois
dans le service j'ai vu d'autres engins
[Musique]
qui lui a donné un document un papier
Signé autorisant ma formation sur la 45
tonnes
j'ai commencé
la formation sur la 45 tonnes le jeûne
que j'ai trouvé sur place qui n'avait
pas pensé un jour rouler ça quand ils
m'ont vu dessus
[Musique]
on va on va le faire et ils ont fait une
liste ils sont allés déposer pour venir
apprendre aussi
à rouler ses engins là
moi je continue à rouler ces engins
mais ça n'a pas été facile
mais par la grâce de Dieu
ça a marché
[Applaudissements]
alors
moi j'ai un message
un message pour les hommes
j'ai été une source de motivation pour
tous ces jeunes là parmi nous chacun à
sa source de motivation
j'ai été encouragé
j'ai été
poussé
à être là où je suis heureuse une
motivation quelque part
alors mon message aux hommes
soutenir vos épouses
encouragez vos
si moi j'ai pu faire tout ça là
c'est grâce à quelqu'un
à un monsieur qui était prêt pour moi
je me sens fatigué ou j'étais dire
c'est pas le moment
et je n'ai pas dès que j'entends ça
c'est comme si il avait un bâton magique
qui en nouvelle la fatigue à moi
toujours il a été là mais pour mieux me
chasser même pour mieux me chasser ils
m'ont mis ennuie ils m'ont donné le
programme de nuit
j'ai dû faire la nuit durant 3 ans et
demi
si tu peux pas tu dégages
durant trois ans et demi quand je rentre
monsieur sort quand monsieur sort je
rentre sauf mon seul jour de repos et il
a été patient il a toujours été là ils
m'ont toujours soutenu un soutien sans
faille
monsieur abossa Cali William mon époux
je voudrais te dire merci
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais te dire je vous ai dit merci
de votre public
merci du coup pour fond de mon cœur
public s'il vous plaît aux pensionnat
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais me dresser à la jeunesse
jeunesse de Côte d'Ivoire
levez-vous
faites quelque chose ceux qui sont à
l'école avancer ne reculez pas ceux dans
celui qui veut dans vos différentes
entreprises foncées votre jeunesse là
c'est à votre avatar
après il faut éviter de le regretter
mais ça en profit et avancer
j'ai aussi un message aussi pour les
dents
femme de Côte d'Ivoire
vous êtes très je voudrais que vous
sachiez que vous êtes très très
important dans une société
et je sais que vous êtes capable
levez vous avancer réaliser vos rêves
ne restez pas comme ça soyez indépendant
ça va vous sauver ça va sauver aussi
également vos enfants
je suis une preuve vivante je suis
devant je suis une preuve vivante ça n'a
pas été facile mais je me suis imposé
par la qualité de mon travail
aujourd'hui
grâce à moi la société veut recruter des
femmes comme chauffeur ils disent que
les femmes
ils disent que les femmes ne font pas
trop d'accidents sont très identiques
que la preuve est là
alors
j'ai tout fait comme je vous ai dit par
la qualité de mon travail et aujourd'hui
je me suis retrouvé la seule femme
chauffeur engins lourd dans tout le
bassassindra pas 1000 plus de 1500
hommes je suis la seule femme
vous pouvez le faire comme de Côte
d'Ivoire foncez réaliser vos rêves la
personne de vous dire que vous ne pouvez
pas le succès que vous pouvez je suis la
première
la source de ma motivation
ainsi dans cette salle
je ne voulais pas que mon enfant vive la
même chose que moi
c'est à partir de là j'ai décidé de
prendre l'argent
cet enfant je pense que mon rêve et
envoie de se réaliser
c'est avant pour qui je me suis tant
battu
aujourd'hui par la grâce de Dieu cette
année 2023
il va sortir
tous ces engins dont je vous ai cité je
le diplôme de tous ces gens
mais par le niveau intellectuel
alors j'ai décidé de retourner à l'école
pour relever mon niveau intellectuel
j'ai passé le CP cette année 2023 je
passe le BEPC
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis fier de toi et je sais que toi
aussi tu es fier de moi
jeunesse de Côte d'Ivoire
jeunesse d'Afrique
jeunesse du monde entier
levez-vous battez-vous
ayez votre indépendance je vous remercie